[Music]
meet Dermot off a go DS fair and I
crawling around on eight legs this
creature has no eyes to appreciate the
kaleidoscope of colors around her she
relies on her extraordinary sense of
smell to lead her to food and safe
places to lay eggs and she's smaller
than a pinhead
Dermott off a go at ease fair and I is a
dust mite less than a tenth the size of
an ant a dust mites whole world is
contained in the dusty film under a bed
or in a forgotten corner this realm is
right under our noses but from our
perspective the tiny specks of brilliant
color blend together into a nondescript
gray what are these colorful microscopic
particles what distinguishes the dust in
your house from say sand on a beach is
that it is a mixture of many different
ingredients it can contain grains of
sand dead skin cells tiny hairs and
threads animal dander pollen man-made
pollutants minerals from outer space and
of course dust mites dust mites eat
animal dander human skin and some fungi
we shed dead skin cells constantly and
wherever we live they mix into the
household dust the same goes for our
pets their dander and hairs enter the
mix as do tiny pieces of thread and
cotton fibers from our clothes these
components make every households dust a
unique blend of bits from its particular
inhabitants household dust also contains
substances that blow in from the wider
world depending on the local geology
finely ground quartz coal or volcanic
ash might enter the air as atmospheric
dust along with pollen and fungal spores
industrial activities also contribute
cement powder particles from car tires
and other chemicals to the airborne mix
the combination of these elements can be
as unique as a fingerprint in Spain
where the land is rich in carbonate
materials dust contains 20 times as much
calcium
as dust in Nigeria where the geology is
quite different after a particularly
violent storm scientists identified dust
from the Sahara Desert thousands of
miles away in London based on its
specific composition in the future we
may be able to pinpoint the origins of
dust samples even more specifically down
to a particular neighborhood or even
house something that may be of great
help for forensic specialists in
addition to markers of humans animals
and landscapes dust also contains
particles from further afield when a
star explodes in a distant galaxy
superhot gases vaporize everything
nearby then the dust settles minerals
condense out of the gas floating out
there between planets and galaxies this
extraterrestrial dust contains tiny
pieces of extinguished stars and the
building blocks of future celestial
bodies every year tens of thousands of
tons of cosmic dust lands on earth and
mingles with terrestrial minerals this
blend of chemicals minerals and
intergalactic particles settles out of
the air onto surfaces in our homes
mixing with the detritus of each houses
occupants stars explode mountains erode
and buildings plants and animals are all
slowly but surely pulverized into fine
grey powder we're all destined to become
dust but it's also possible that we came
from it interstellar dust has been found
to carry organic compounds through space
it's possible that billions of years ago
some of these cosmic particles were the
seed of life on our little blue planet
have you ever visited Ted Ed's patreon
page every donation helps support our
nonprofit mission and there are some
pretty cool perks including discounts
for the ted-ed shop exclusive digital
downloads of amazing art from our
lessons and
more
[Music]